hello believe nation it's time to pick
the winners of the book contest alright
so as exciting the day is finally here a
lot of you submitted some amazing
entries we're going to do a giveaway of
ten autographed books with a customized
message sent directly potentially to
your house a lot of you entered in with
some cool stuff and I actually had Nina
pick the winners so if you are one of
the winners you could thank Nina because
she's the one who picked you and if
you're not one of the winners you could
blame me because I asked Nina to do it
that's leadership right you give away
the glory and you take all the crap so
if you liked it give a shout out to Nina
and if not you can hate on me so here it
is our ten winners good luck okay happy
Monday guys I'm Nina evidence not home
right now he asked me to record the the
book contest video i hope i will do a
good job bear with me guys okay so i
look over all the cons are the videos
and the links dad have been sent in and
i have picked my top tens the first one
I picked Rhonda Rhonda has been around
for a long time I saw a lot of her
comment and really like her I pick her
it's not because I like her wall yes I
like her but I pick her because she did
a really good job off the videos she not
only make one video she made two videos
she talked about her one word Stan and
also she laid out why she picked the one
worse than so she spent a lot of time
and effort and really good video thumbs
up so that's my first pick actually the
order does not matter it's not like who
did the best who did the least but this
is my that's what I have in my notes
and these are the people I pick second
contest that I pic is Zeno so you know I
love you you've been here for a long
time as well you've been around you're
always in Evans gratitude video whenever
I'm there I see you there thank you for
a dl support Evan loved your support as
well so the reason I pick Zeno's video
because he has a fire plays in the
background I love fireplace just so you
know whenever we go camping always I
could just sit there for an hour's hours
watch the fires it's very calm and
soothing but yes it's good video and
also see no laid out all the the
importance of finding the one words and
people could hate it people could love
it so and he tell people to embrace it
so it's good i like i like it very very
good the third one I pick is dis girl
she her one were it's autumn ism she's
very like Evan once she has a mindset
for something she goes for it she told a
couple of her personal stories so the
first story she was telling I was she go
on a future she told her classmate she
want to be in that school and she ended
up she went to desk oh so it's very like
Evans and I also liked her plant I'm a
big plans person so she has a J plan in
her video I'd really like it and she
told me that her plan has once bloom mmm
I want to know how for the fourth one
the reason why I picked the fourth one
is because it's a teen entrepreneur we
gotta help teen entrepreneur for most of
you who watch a lot of Evans video he
has told a story about him and her
sister when they were kids like four
year when her sister were three years
old four years old there were not to
sell some kind of parts I could be wrong
I don't remember but they did they did
that oh the fifth one this is actually
very creative I really like this one a
lot it's at your art the one
were booked pour into electronic device
cell phone that really like that very
creative get you up guy the sixth one
that I picked this guy he actually got a
one more book when you open it it's
blank nothing is showing on the book he
show his top 10 favorite quote from all
the front of book so very good I really
like it so the seventh one that I picked
it this video it's a teaser video off
the one word book it's very cool that he
made a teaser video and it's teasing the
the audience that oh you should read
this book I like it okay for the 81 I
gotta pick this one because it has a
t-mo character on the bottom corner and
Evan or he plays the legend he always
picked emo and tim o's one word its
shroom very funny very creative I really
like it I said really like it a lot but
I do I like it it's very cool very funny
thumbs up the ninth one that I picked
it's a very funny picture this guy who's
sitting in the cold water it's a winter
time and he's out there reading Evans
one word book and he won't he wouldn't
go in because he needs to find his one
word before you go in so it's very funny
good job so the tenth one the tenth one
I pick as it's very funny actually
Christina also sent an email to Evan
said that this video she has boobs she
has to be one of the top 10 picks she
designed cakes she made two cakes one is
Evans one word book and another one is
the belief logo and she'll be sending
these two to Evan but I'll be opening it
too so I really like it mmm yummy cakes
my mouth is watering so these are the
top ten that I've picked for the contest
but I do have two bonuses for Evans teen
first one will be
indra shine whose evans assistant thank
you for your support and i did look at
your contest the pictures are very very
nice very creative you put a lot of time
in there thank you so much and thank you
for the ongoing support for the second
link bonus is JJ rice he has filmed this
video with his roommate length they have
laid out all the books that Jade rice
has purchased he also showed the the
Wanda Evans given him with a message and
with the senator so thank you Jay Reise
for the ongoing support we're going to
give a one of the book the one word book
to your roommate links thank you so much
guys for watching so these are the top
10 people have picked for the contest
and I hope you guys enjoyed the book and
enjoy the message if and will be put it
on the book by so that's it those are
our winners thank you guys so much for
all your entries I'm humbled and I
really really appreciate you pour in
your art into expressing something for
your one word and I hope that the book
is having an impact on your life for the
winners make sure to contact me shoot me
an email send me a message on YouTube I
need your address I need your full name
or whatever you want to be in the book
and need to have a little bit of detail
sent off to me I'll make sure the book
is sent off to you I've got some more
fun book stuff in the coming weeks so
stay tuned I look forward to giving you
guys an update but until then I believe
in you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon